[Musique]
la séance est reprise
et nous
appelons l'addition du projet de Loire
rejeté par l'Assemblée nationale à
engagement de la procédure accélérée
d'approbation des comptes de la sécurité
de la sécurité sociale pour l'année 2022
et dans la décision générale la parole
est d'abord à Monsieur François braune
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur général
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs
thématiques mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs
à l'image du flux sanguin dans le corps
humain les finances publiques sont une
matière vivante un fluide qui circule
dans l'état et irrigue la société
elles sont autant les moyens de l'action
publique que le vecteur des engagements
est priorités politiques qu'elles
portent
c'est encore plus vrai quand on se
penche sur les finances sociales
il faut en effet se rappeler que les
dépenses et les recettes de la sécurité
sociale brassent des masses financières
supérieures à celles du budget de l'État
le budget de la Sécurité sociale est
ainsi un objet incarné et concret qui
est l'un des coeurs battants de notre
démocratie tant par l'importance de son
volume financier que parce que ces flux
d'argent public représentent l'effort
solidairement consenti par la nation en
faveur de la santé des familles de
l'autonomie ou encore des retraites de
nos concitoyens
aussi depuis leur création en 1996 les
lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale se sont imposés comme le
principal outil de contrôle
parlementaire et de pilotage des
finances sociales leur discussion est
devenue un moment majeur de la vie
démocratique durant lequel les
parlementaires approuvent les grandes
orientations politiques partées par
l'ensemble des branches ainsi que les
prévisions de recettes et les objectifs
de dépenses qui déterminent des
conditions de leur équilibre financier
la naissance des droits de financement
de la sécurité sociale fut un virage
important et en quelque sorte la
première étape constitutive d'un plus
vaste mouvement d'affirmation du rôle de
contrôle du Parlement qui s'est
progressivement renforcé au cours des
trois dernières décennies le texte que
nous a examinons ce soir en constitué la
plus récente expression
mesdames et messieurs pour reprendre les
mots d'Alain Lambert prédécesseur de mon
collègue Gabriel Attal au ministère du
Budget et qui a également longtemps
siéger dans cette hémicycle le contrôle
parlementaire sur les finances publiques
est une ardente obligation sans laquelle
les fonctions du Parlement ne seraient
être réellement exercées ce terme de
contrôle recoupe en réalité deux
fonctions distinctes et tout à fait
complémentaires il renvoie d'une part un
exercice de suivi des crédits
budgétaires afin de contrôler la
régularité et l'effectivité de la
dépense publique mais il y a aussi mais
il y a aussi ouvert la voie d'autre part
un exercice d'évaluation de l'usage et
de l'effet de la dépense publique afin
de déterminer si celle-ci a atteint les
objectifs en posant le cas échéant la
question de leur amélioration d'un
exercice à l'autre
cette notion d'évaluation des politiques
publiques est ainsi devenu indissociable
de votre mission constitutionnelle le
contrôle de l'action gouvernementale
elle est d'ailleurs gravée depuis 2008
dans notre loi fondamentale dans la
lignée de la loi organique relative aux
lois de finances de 2001 nous avons
collectivement fondé l'espoir de faire
émerger une culture véritable et
partagée de l'évaluation dans notre pays
aujourd'hui je me réjouis de voir que
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
suscite un intérêt toujours croissant et
surtout qu'elles tiennent une place de
plus en plus importante dans notre
système institutionnel
le fait de rendre des comptes c'est
également essentiel au regard de la
transparence que nous devons à nos
concitoyens rappelons-le chaque euro
dépensé au titre de nos politiques
sociales c'est l'argent des Français
enfin la modernisation de notre cadre
général des finances publiques et
notamment l'importance croissante de
l'intégration européenne
particulièrement depuis la mise en place
en 2011 du semestre européen soutiennent
aussi cette exigence de consolidation
d'une vision financière prospective
analytique et articulée
dans ces domaines 2023 est ainsi
également une année à marquer d'une
pierre blanche dans l'histoire de
finances sociales
ce projet de loi il a été créé par vous
pour vous
c'est pourquoi je regrette le symbole
envoyé par son rejet à l'Assemblée
nationale même si ces implications
pratiques sont dans les faits très
limitées désormais comme pour le budget
de l'État la probation des comptes de la
Sécurité sociale de l'année écoulée fait
l'objet d'un texte séparé alors qu'ils
étaient jusqu'ici arrêtés au sein de la
première partie du PLFSS ainsi
parallèlement aux travaux du printemps
de l'évaluation ce projet de loi permet
de renforcer l'information et la
participation des représentants de la
nation aux travaux sur la situation des
côtes sociaux et surtout d'en intégrer
en amont les résultats au débat
entourant les échéances budgétaires de
l'automne comme c'était le cas déjà pour
les lois de finances avec la loi de
règlement
ce nouveau schéma correspond bien mieux
à la réalité à la temporalité des
finances sociales avec les autres
avancées permissent par l'adoption de la
loi organique du 14 mars 2022 tel que
l'intégration de la dette des hôpitaux
et des établissements médico-sociaux au
PLFSS ou encore l'enrichissement et la
rationalisation de ces annexes en ce qui
concerne donc la présentation de
l'exécution de ces comptes sociaux
permettez-moi de m'arrêter en
particulier sur l'exécution de la
branche maladie
on peut dire que 2022 et après
l'explosion des dépenses en 2020 et 2021
en quelque sorte le dernier véritable
budget covid car si certains surco
exceptionnels liés à la pandémie ont
encore perduré dans l'exercice 2023
c'est de façon résiduelle
il faudra rappeler un budget un tableau
de résultats et toujours indissociable
de son contexte un chiffre en soit ça ne
veut rien dire
aussi le seul de négatif à -21 milliards
d'euros de la branche maladie ne
provient pas d'une mauvaise gestion il
s'explique essentiellement par la prise
en compte des effets de la crise
sanitaire et de l'inflation qui sont des
chocs exogènes que nous avons dû
absorber pour protéger notre système de
santé
ces 21 milliards d'euros supportés en
plus de ces recettes par la branche
maladie c'est bien pour assurer la prise
en charge des dépenses de santé et
garantir l'accès aux soins de tous les
assurés
il faut aussi dire ce chiffre dans un
contexte temporel
après que la pandémie est fait plonger
ce solde à moins 30,5 milliards d'euros
en 2020 le résultat de la branche
maladie de 2022 s'inscrit dans une
trajectoire positive de retour à la
normale progressif après la première
amélioration de 2021 où ce solde était
remonté à - 26,1 milliard d'euros soit
une résorption du sol négatif supérieur
à 5 milliards d'euros en un an
on voit bien en regardant ses comptes de
2022 dans leur ensemble et dans le temps
qu'il réponde à ce double impératif de
rechercher constamment l'équilibre entre
la maîtrise de l'évolution des dépenses
tout en continuant d'améliorer l'état de
santé de la population
par ailleurs il faut noter que la
branche ATMP voit son excédent
s'améliorer à 1,7 milliards d'euros
plus largement au-delà des dépenses
exceptionnelles de 2022 il faut
souligner que la trajectoire de dondam
22 s'inscrit dans une hausse constante
depuis 2017 des moyens alloués à la
santé comme le reflet de l'ambition
prioritaire que le Président de la
République accorde à ce sujet
les fortes dépenses de ces dernières
années ce n'est pas que de la gestion de
crise c'est aussi de l'investissement
dans notre système de santé de
l'investissement dans les
infrastructures en rénovant et
reconstruisant nos établissements de
santé de l'investissement dans nos
ressources humaines par une hausse
historique du point d'indice la plus
forte depuis 37 ans qui a bien
évidemment bénéficié à la fonction
publique hospitalière par les
revalorisations du Ségur et la mission
flash sur les urgences et soins non
programmés de l'été dernier encore une
fois cela se fait dans une trajectoire
positive mais responsable puisqu'en 2022
la situation financière des régimes de
base de la sécurité sociale s'est
amélioré avec un déficit des régimes de
base du Fonds de solidarité vieillesse
de 19,6 milliards soit une réduction de
4,6 milliards d'euros par rapport à 2021
c'est bien sûr le fait du repli des
dépensiers à la crise sanitaire mais
aussi il faut le souligner du dynamisme
des recettes lié au rebond de l'activité
économique et de l'emploi les recettes
de ces régimes ont progressé de 5,4% en
2022 alors que l'INSEE enregistrait 337
000 créations nettes d'emploi en 2022 et
près de 1,7 millions de création nette
d'emplois depuis 2017
pour les années à venir le gouvernement
réaffirme sa détermination à réduire le
déficit de la Sécurité sociale et à
garantir le financement de notre modèle
de protection sociale qui est la
condition de sa pérennité
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs ce nouveau rendez-vous estival
pour les deux chambres du Parlement vous
devez l'envisager comme un outil
supplémentaire qui améliore
l'information des représentants de la
nation sur nos finances sociales
renforce la propriété des lois de
finances de la sécurité sociale et
rationalise les débats
que l'on partage ou non les choix
politiques du gouvernement ce
rendez-vous est toujours utile pour
tirer les leçons de l'année écoulée et
mieux préparer collectivement la
prochaine loi de financement
le Sénat a largement voté en février
2022 le projet de loi organique
instaurant cette nouvelle loi
d'approbation des comptes sociaux
c'est pourquoi dans le cadre de la
dynamique de renforcement de
l'évaluation de nos équilibres
financiers par le Parlement je vous
invite à voter ce texte pour vous saisir
pleinement de ce nouvel instrument que
vous avez souhaité et qui vous êtes
offert je vous remercie
la table ministre délégué chargé des
comptes publics
madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur général
des affaires sociales monsieur le
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs les déficits se résorbent mais
nous sommes encore loin de l'équilibre
telle est l'image des finances de la
sécurité sociale dont j'ai l'honneur de
vous rendre compte avec François Brown à
l'occasion du débat sur ce projet de loi
d'approbation des comptes de la Sécurité
sociale pour 2022 avant d'aborder mon
propos permettez-moi de dire la
reconnaissance et la gratitude du
gouvernement et je crois pouvoir le dire
à travers vous de la nation et de ses
représentants envers les 120 000 agents
des caisses de sécurité sociale le plus
d'un million d'agents de la fonction
publique hospitalière et des centaines
de milliers de professionnels de santé
sociaux médico-sociaux qui donnent au
quotidien un sens aux mots sécurité
sociale
la sécurité sociale est l'une des
grandesertés de notre pays elle donne
corps à notre devise nationale la
liberté de pouvoir entreprendre sa vie
en étant accompagné pour cela notamment
en matière de politique familiale
l'égalité notamment devant l'accès aux
soins la fraternité à travers nos
dispositifs de solidarité je veux ici
remercier toutes celles et ceux qui
dédient leur vie professionnelle à
accompagner les Français au moment les
plus importants de leur vie personnelle
ou familiale la petite enfance la
parentalité la maladie la retraite ou la
perte d'autonomie nos débats prévus par
la loi organique du 14 mars 2022
permettent pour la première fois
d'examiner dès le printemps les contes
de l'année passée comme pour le budget
de l'État s'agissant des contes de la
sécurité sociale si je regarde le
panorama en 2022 trois branches sur 5
affiche un sol de positif en particulier
je suis fier que la branche autonomie
créée par la majorité présidentielle à
travers les lois d'août 2020 affiche un
excédent de 200 millions d'euros deux
branches restent en déficit la branche
maladie et la branche retraite par
rapport à 2021 le sol de la sécurité
sociale s'améliore de 4,6 milliards
d'euros ce qui est d'abord le fruit
d'une politique économique qui
fonctionne en 2022 les recettes de la
sécurité sociale ont progressé de près
de 30 milliards d'euros c'est la
conséquence directe d'une masse
salariale qui a augmenté de 8,9% et des
337 000 créations nets d'emploi l'an
passé d'après les derniers chiffres de
l'Insee si je regarde depuis 2017 avec
1,7 millions d'emplois nets créés se
sont au total plus de 25 milliards
d'euros de cotisations en plus par an
dans les caisses de notre sécurité
sociale plus d'emplois moins de chômage
c'est plus d'argent pour nos hôpitaux
nos crèches et nos EHPAD pour le dire
autrement s'il n'y avait pas eu 1,7
millions d'emplois créés depuis 2017 le
déficit de notre sécurité sociale serait
plus lourd de 25 milliards d'euros c'est
pour moi aussi une réponse à celles et
ceux qui remettent en cause la politique
économique menée par ce gouvernement
précisément cette politique économique
en faisant reculer le chômage et en
améliorant l'emploi améliore aussi les
caisses de la Sécurité sociale je le
rappelle à cette tribune comme je l'ai
fait lors de nos précédents débats oui
pour nous c'est le travail qui crée la
richesse dans toutes les
circonscriptions de France où je me
déplace je ne croise pas un seul salarié
ou un seul patron qui me demande
d'augmenter les prélèvements qui pèsent
sur le travail au contraire je rencontre
des travailleurs des classes moyennes
qui nous demandent de baisser leurs
impôts de soutenir leur pouvoir d'achat
je vois des patrons de TPE de PME qui
cherchent à recruter mais n'y
parviennent pas toujours je rencontre
des indépendants qui nous remercient
d'avoir allégé leur cotisations durant
la crise mais qui demande moins de
complexité et de bureaucratie dans le
système social
s'agissant des dépenses c'est l'induites
par la crise sanitaire ce sont
logiquement réduites passant de 18,3
milliards en 2021 à 11,7 milliards
d'euros en 2022 elles ont notamment
permis de financer la réalisation de 139
millions de tests de dépistage au cours
de l'année passée nous avons continué
début 2022 à soutenir les entreprises
fermées ou affectées par les
restrictions sanitaires avec près de 9
milliards d'euros d'exonération et
d'aide au paiement des cotisations
sociales entre 2020 et 2022 compenser
évidemment par le budget de l'État le
budget de l'État justement a continué à
honorer ses dettes envers la sécurité
sociale grâce au remboursement intervenu
fin 2022 pour la troisième année
consécutive en 2022 l'État n'est plus
débiteur mais créancier de la sécurité
sociale pour 100 millions d'euros alors
qu'il avait accumulé au cours de la
décennie passée des dettes s'élevant
parfois jusqu'au milliards d'euros c'est
aussi un progrès pour la transparence de
nos comptes et dans les relations
financières entre l'État et la sécurité
sociale
en 2022 nous avons aussi mis en oeuvre
des mesures d'économie et de maîtrise
pour dégager des marges de manoeuvre sur
le budget de l'assurance maladie la
poursuite de l'effort en faveur de la
pertinence des soins a permis des gains
de 200 millions d'euros la baisse des
prix des médicaments dont le brevet est
tombé dans le domaine public ont permis
des gains de près d'un milliard d'euros
réinvestis pour près de la moitié pour
410 millions d'euros dans le soutien à
la production en France des médicaments
les plus innovants parallèlement nous
avons poursuivi l'investissement
indispensable dans notre système de
santé et singulièrement pour notre
hôpital public engagé avec le Ségur en
2022 le Ségur de la Santé a représenté
un effort budgétaire de 12,7 milliards
d'euros pour les personnels des
établissements sanitaires et
médico-sociaux en un quinquennat l'ONDAM
établissement de santé est passé de 79
milliards d'euros en 2017 à 98,4
milliards d'euros en 2022 soit une
progression de près de 20 milliards
d'euros plus 25% en 5 ans c'est
historique
sur la branche famille nous tirons
toutes les conséquences du rapport de la
Cour des comptes et de son refus dans
certifié les comptes je note que ce
n'est pas l'équilibre de la branche
famille qui est en cause puisqu'elle
reste excédentaire de 1,9 milliards
d'euros quant aux erreurs de calcul des
prestations versées par les Cafres que
la Cour des comptes souligne a juste
titre nous avons d'ores et déjà annoncé
des mesures majeures pour y remédier la
majorité de ces erreurs portent sur le
RSA et la prime d'activité pour
fiabiliser leurs calculs la notion de
montant net social apparaîtra dès ce
mois de juillet sur les bulletins de
paie ils permettra aux Français de
connaître avec précision les ressources
à déclarer dans les formulaires de
demande d'allocation auprès des CAF cela
réduira les erreurs de bonne foi et
facilitera le travail de nos agents en
parallèle nous expérimentons dans
plusieurs cas le pré remplissage des
ressources sur les formulaires de
demande du RSA et de la prime d'activité
c'est la première étape du chantier de
la solidarité à la source voulue par le
président de la République et soutenu
j'en suis sûr par une large majorité de
cette hémicycle concrètement
2025 chaque allocataire verra ses
ressources très remplies dans les
formulaires de RSA et de la prime
d'activité cela réduira drastiquement
les erreurs mais aussi la fraude ce sera
une petite révolution pour l'accès aux
droits et la simplification
administrative nous investissons
également dans la modernisation des
systèmes d'information des caisses de
sécurité sociale pour mettre en œuvre
les recommandations de la Cour des
comptes avec un plan d'un milliard
d'euros sur le quinquennat qui permettra
par exemple au CAF de récupérer des
indus frauduleux sur une profondeur de 5
ans contre seulement deux ans
aujourd'hui
évaluer simplifier mais aussi bien sûr
réduire les déficits pour le budget de
la Sécurité sociale comme pour l'État
résorber nos déficits et rembourser
notre dette est une exigence de
souveraineté pour notre génération et de
justice pour les prochaines générations
c'est l'horizon fixée par le Président
de la République et la première ministre
pour permettre à notre pays de réduire
son déficit de deux points de PIB d'ici
2027 et d'accélérer notre désendettement
je le dis très franchement on ne peut
pas défendre l'indépendance de la France
tout en critiquant le principe de
réduction des déficits on ne peut pas
davantage critiquer le poids des marchés
financiers mais rechercher leur
financement à travers toujours plus de
dettes publiques réduire ses dettes
c'est aussi se libérer des marchés
financiers payer ses dettes c'est dire
haut et fort que la France n'a qu'une
parole que quand la France s'endette
elle rembourse c'est à dire que la
France est une grande puissance
économique et financière en laquelle les
investisseurs peuvent avoir confiance
pour la quatrième année consécutive nous
restons le pays le plus attractif
d'Europe pour les investissements
étrangers les investissements annoncés
lors du dernier sommet tchus France
représenteront 13 milliards d'euros et
8000 créations d'aide d'emploi notamment
dans les batteries les panneaux
photovoltaïques le médicament ou encore
l'automobile
ce sont autant de recettes
supplémentaires pour la sécurité sociale
dans les années à venir enfin je veux
conclure sur l'exigence qui doit nous
rassembler de mener une lutte inlassable
et implacable contre toutes les fraudes
j'ai présenté ces dernières semaines en
arsenal de mesure pour aller beaucoup
plus loin et beaucoup plus fort contre
la fraude fiscale contre la fraude
douanière et contre la fraude sociale
sur la fraude sociale l'année 2022
témoignait déjà de nos résultats plus
50% de redressement des Urssaf par
rapport à 2017 dans leur lutte contre le
travail au noir avec 788 millions
d'euros l'an passé plus 30% de fraude
détectée et éviter par l'assurance
maladie avec 316 millions d'euros plus
30% également pour les cafs et les
caisses de retraite avec 506 millions
d'euros en 2022 nous évaluons mieux les
fraudes et donc nous les connaissons
mieux l'assurance maladie approfondie
son travail d'évaluation des fraudes
secteur par secteur la branche famille a
évalué à 2,8 milliards d'euros les
fraudes en 2021 et reproduira l'exercice
cette année la fraude aux cotisations a
été évaluée à milliards d'euros par le
Haut Conseil au financement de la
protection sociale la branche vieillesse
a évalué pour la première fois les
fraudes environ 200 millions d'euros sur
son périmètre j'installerai dans les
prochaines semaines le comité
d'évaluation des fraudes qui fournira en
matière sociale comme en matière fiscale
et douanière des évaluations régulières
en associant administration expert
indépendant et bien sûr parlementaire
nous évaluons mieux nous repérons
davantage les fraudes et nous les
sanctionnons plus fermement en 2022 plus
de 30 000 fraudes aux allocations
versées par les CAF ont donné lieu à une
pénalité financière en plus je
recouvrement des sommes dues un dossier
sur 10 est suivi de poursuite pénales en
matière de travail illégal des
entreprises plus de 200 millions d'euros
de majorations ont été mises en
recouvrement en plus du redressement des
sommes non déclarées de même que 27
millions d'euros d'exonération de
cotisations sociales ont été remboursées
par des entreprises recourant au travail
illégal au total sur le précédent
quinquennat 3,5 milliards d'euros ont
été redressés au titre du travail
dissimulé c'est l'équivalent de 300
millions de vaccins contre la grippe de
140 millions de consultations chez le
médecin généraliste ou de 4 millions
d'allocations de rentrée scolaire oui
nous pouvons être fiers de ce bilan qui
nous donne aujourd'hui la force d'aller
encore plus loin au cours de ce mandat
avec François Brown avec Jean-Christophe
con avec l'ensemble de mes collègues du
gouvernement je poursurai inlassablement
cette lutte contre toutes les fraudes
fiscales sociales douanières ou la
fraude aux aides publiques parce que
cette lutte conditionne la confiance de
nos concitoyens dans la parole et la
puissance publique et nous leur devons
et je poursuivrai évidemment avec mes
collègues mon soutien absolu au service
de la sécurité sociale et de toutes les
hommes de tous les hommes et de toutes
les femmes qui la font vivre je vous
remercie
la parole est maintenant Madame
Elisabeth d'oiseau rapporteur général de
la commission des affaires sociales
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres madame la Présidente de la
Commission mes chers collègues
notre séance d'aujourd'hui marque une
petite révolution vous l'avez les uns et
les autres déjà dit dans l'examen des
finances sociales par le Parlement
puisqu'il s'agit de l'examen du 1er
projet de loi d'approbation des comptes
de la Sécurité sociale ou l'axe
vous l'avez dit la sécurité sociale
c'est notre bien le plus précieux
puisqu'elle assure la protection sociale
de l'ensemble de nos concitoyens alors
monsieur le ministre de la Santé de la
prévention vous avez utilisé une
métaphore j'ai envie de la poursuivre en
disant que là peut-être que la sécurité
sociale est un peu sous perfusion
puisque malheureusement la dette est
importante et qu'elle continue de courir
les plaques ou les lacs si on considère
les lois proprement dites ont été
instaurées par la loi organique du 14
mars 2022 rappelez-vous et le résultat
d'une proposition de loi organique de
Thomas Meunier alors rapporteur général
de la commission des affaires sociales
de l'Assemblée nationale et s'inspirant
largement sur ce point d'une proposition
de loi organique de Jean-Marie
vadorenberg alors rapporteur général de
la commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat
les lacs se correspondent à l'ancienne
premier partie des lois de financement
de la sécurité sociale examinée à
l'automne et c'est sûr nous nous
réjouissons de ce printemps-été puisque
c'est un peu maintenant tardif du débat
social que nous engageons aujourd'hui
le projet de loi d'approbation des
contes de la sécurité sociale doit être
déposée avant le 1er juin afin de
favoriser un chaînage vertueux avec le
PLFSS afin de favoriser ce chaînage
vertu entre plaque cplfss le rapport
annuel de la Cour des comptes sur
l'application des lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale jusqu'à leur publie
à l'automne et désormais conjoint au
dépôt du place
malheureusement les conditions d'examen
de ce premier plaque se sont loin d'être
idéales mais je veux croire qu'il s'agit
de simples difficultés passagères venant
de la nécessité de chacun de s'adapter à
ce nouveau contexte mais il est vrai que
nous avions beaucoup débattu leur de cet
examen de la loi organique et il nous
semblait plein de promesses pour
débattre avec un certain nombre
d'informations sur l'efficacité et
l'efficience de nos lois concernant la
sécurité sociale comme vous le savez la
commission adoptait une motion ce n'est
pas une surprise je l'imagine pendant à
opposer la question préalable cela
s'explique par trois raisons dont
chacune la justifie à elle seule
la première raison est le refus de la
Cour des comptes de certifier des
comptes 2022 de la CNAV et de la branche
famille en conséquence de l'augmentation
des erreurs dans le paiement des
prestations
dans le cadre de l'indicateur à 24 mois
je voudrais rappeler que les erreurs à
la hausse ou à la baisse pour les
prestations versées en 2021 était de
7,6% contre un mieux quand même en 2019
puisque c'était à 5,5%. à moins de
considérer que l'exercice de
certification par la Cour des comptes
n'a aucune importance nous n'avons
d'autres choix que de rejeter des
comptes 2022 c'est donc la première
raison
le deuxième motif de recours à la
question préalable l'absence de prise en
compte dans l'annexe patrimonial de la
correction relative au compte 2021
effectué à l'initiative du Sénat je le
rappelle lors de l'examen du PLFSS 2023
afin d'imputer sur 2021 un produit de 5
milliards d'euros résultant de la
régularisation des cotisations qui
étaient dues par les travailleurs
indépendants comme le demandait
d'ailleurs la Cour des comptes qui avait
refusé de certifier des comptes 2021 de
l'exercice de l'activité de recouvrement
je voudrais rappeler que le Conseil
constitutionnel a confirmé notre
approche sur le vrai déficit le tableau
patrimonial que le gouvernement propose
d'annexer à la laque se comprend pour
comparaison une colonne relative à
l'exercice 2021 21 cette colonne ne
prend pas en compte la correction
effectuée par le Parlement
cela justifie également à soi seul le
recours à la question préalable sinon ça
reviendrait à contredire les travaux et
les conclusions du Sénat lors du PLFSS
janvier au troisième et dernier motif de
recours à la question préalable qui est
l'absence de conformité aux exigences de
la Loire organique de certaines années
un premier sujet est que les rapports
d'évaluation des politiques de sécurité
sociale ou reps ont habituellement des
indicateurs qui s'arrêtent en 2020 ou en
2021 et non en 2022 comme on pourrait
l'attendre s'agissant d'une loi
d'approbation des contes 2022 le
chaînage vertueux entre plaques et plff
n'est pas possible si des chiffres des
reps ne sont pas à jour comment débattre
en effet de l'efficacité de l'efficience
des dépenses de sécurité sociale sans
les chiffres des trois dernières années
or un certain nombre d'éléments nous
manquent
un autre cas de non-conformité des
annexes de la loi organique c'est que
l'annexe 2 ne comprend pas l'évaluation
de l'efficacité d'un tiers des niches
sociales prévues par la loi organique le
plaque 2023 devra fournir une évaluation
d'un tiers des niches comme le prévoit
la loi organique je rappelle que le
rapport que vous aviez commandé
igfiga sur ce sujet fait disproportition
notamment pour fixer le champ des
mesures devant être évalués et pour
déterminer la norme de référence
c'est-à-dire la situation par rapport à
laquelle les niches sont
comment chiffrer
donc là encore il y a je dirais une
promesse non tenue ce contexte
particulier fait que le grand débat sur
les finances sociales et les politiques
de sécurité sociale que les plaques se
sont censées favoriser ne pourra avoir
lieu cette année faute de compte exact
et d'annexe se conforme à la loi
organique
je me contenterai donc de renvoyer à ce
sujet à la contribution que constitue le
rapport de la commission je rappellerai
brièvement les principaux points
la Commission constate le dérapage des
dépenses de santé qui ne s'expliquent
plus par la seule crise sanitaire comme
la Cour des comptes elle estime
nécessaire de rétablir le seuil d'alerte
en cas de risque de dépassement de l'âme
de 0,5 % sans distinction entre dépenses
covid et non covid s'agissant de la mise
en oeuvre des dispositions de la loi de
finances de sécurité sociale 2022 la
Commission a souhaité aborder quatre
sujets
dans le cas de la clause de sauvegarde
des médicaments qui s'est transformé en
une taxe indiscriminée et imprévisible
de plus d'un milliard d'euros sur les
entreprises pharmaceutiques la
Commission souhaite que la mission
interministérielle récemment constituée
par la première ministre sur la
régulation des dépenses de produits de
santé soit l'occasion une vraie occasion
de s'interroger sur la pertinence et sur
l'ampleur du dispositif
dans le cas de la garantie de
financement des hôpitaux la Commission
souligne la nécessité de préciser
rapidement les modalités de sortie en
effet en 2022 c'est une dépense de 2,7
milliards d'euros après 1,9 milliards
d'euros en 2021 et encore avant 2,5
milliards d'euros en 2020 c'est à dire
qu'on dépense plus que l'année où elle a
été mise en oeuvre dans le cas de la
généralisation de l'intermédiation des
pensions alimentaires la Commission
souligne qu'il convient de rester
vigilant sur la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme dont le succès implique la bonne
information des parents le respect par
les avocats de leur obligation de
transmission de dossiers à la Ripa et de
la part de la Ripa la gestion d'un fort
afflux de dossiers qui ne devra pas
empêcher l'augmentation du taux de
recouvrement des impayés enfin la
Commission considère qu'il faut mettre
effectivement en œuvre la réforme des
services autonomie à domicile la loi
prévoit que le décret fixant le cahier
des charges doit être pris au plus tard
le 30 2023 or nous sommes le 3 juillet
messieurs les ministres ou en
sommes-nous enfin la Commission a
souhaité s'intéresser au sujet
d'actualité de la fraude sociale on sait
maintenant grâce au rapport de la Cour
des comptes sur l'application des lois
de financement de la sécurité sociale de
mai dernier que la fraude de prestation
coûte entre 6 et 8 milliards d'euros le
30 mai vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
ministre vous avez annoncé un plan de
lutte contre la fraude sociale ce plan
nous semble aller dans le bon sens il y
a des éléments politiques positifs mes
propos il faudra toutefois éviter que la
focalisation sur le sujet médiatique des
cartes vitales surnuméraires amènent à
se détourner des principaux enjeux de
lutte contre la fraude on sait qu'entre
2019 et 2022 on est passé de 600 000 à
3000 cartes perdues en fait elles n'ont
pas été désactivées il faut le dire
parce que ça reste encore dans l'opinion
une légende il faudra également
s'assurer que les dispositions
législatives sont effectivement
appliquées et que l'augmentation des
moyens n'est pas un simple effet
d'annonce en somme messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues il me
semble que nous nous trouvons au milieu
du gué le Plax 2022 n'est pas encore à
la hauteur de ce qu'impose la révision
organique de 2022 il reprend des comptes
2021 et 2022 erroné et ses annexes ne
respectent pas certaines dispositions
importantes de la loi organique
toutefois ces problèmes n'ont pas
vocation à se reproduire chaque année on
peut supposer et je l'espère que les
prochains plaques présenteront des
comptes exacts certifiés par la Cour des
comptes que les reps seront à jour et
que les niches sociales seront
effectivement évaluées cela rendra
possible de tenir à la frontière entre
les deuxièmes et 3e trimestre le grand
débat sur les finances sociales et les
politiques de sécurité sociale qui sont
la raison d'être des plaques et que la
commission des affaires sociales appelle
de ses vœux je vous remercie de votre
attention
la parole est maintenant à Christian
Klinger pour la commission des finances
et rapporteur pour avis
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues donc nous examinons
aujourd'hui le premier projet de loi
d'approbation des contes de la sécurité
sociale pour 2022 qui est au compte
social ce que la loi de règlement est au
compte de l'état suivant une tendance
récente ce projet de loi a été rejeté
par l'Assemblée nationale la commission
des finances saisie pour avis a donné à
ce texte un avis défavorable dont je
vais brièvement exposer les raisons le
tableau présenté à l'article premier qui
concerne les comptes de l'ensemble des
régimes obligatoires de base et du fond
de solidarité vieillesse fait apparaître
un déficit de 19,6 milliards d'euros
dont un déficit de 21 milliards d'euros
pour les 5 branches de la sécurité
sociale et un léger d'excédent de 1,3
milliards d'euros pour le FSB
la situation de la branche maladie
toujours en rémission après la crise
sanitaire est particulièrement
préoccupante elle concentra elle seule
un déficit aussi important que celui de
l'ensemble de la sécurité sociale 21
milliards d'euros les dépenses sont en
effet plus élevées que les recettes je
commence par les recettes les ressources
de la sécurité sociale et du FSV ont
dépassé les prévisions de la LSS 2022
elle s'établisse à 572 milliards d'euros
cette progression rapide résulte
essentiellement d'une conjoncture
favorable et non d'un quelconque effort
en recette du gouvernement la croissance
de la masse salariale du secteur privé
sur laquelle sont assises les
cotisations sociales a ainsi cru de 8,7%
en 2022 mais il s'agit là d'une
situation exceptionnelle qui a toutes
les chances de ne pas se reproduire la
progression des recettes est donc à
ralentir j'en viens aux dépenses les
charges nette de la sécurité sociale et
du FSV se sont élevés en 2022 à 591,6
milliards d'euros en augmentation de
24,3 milliards par rapport à 2021 et
surtout de Vannes par rapport aux
prévisions de la LSS 2022 la situation
sanitaire dégradée du fait de la vague
au micro les 12,7 milliards d'euros
consacrés au Ségur de la santé et les
revalorisations des prestations de 1,8%
au 1er avril puis de 4% au 1er juillet
2022 en sont responsables
les dépenses de la branche maladie et
singulièrement de l'ONDAM se distingue
par leur dynamisme l'ONDAM connaît ainsi
un dépassement de 4,4%
la situation des autres branches est
contrastée celle de la branche
vieillesse est préoccupante elle connaît
un déficit de 3,8 milliards d'euros en
2022 principalement du fait des
revalorisations des prestations ce
déficit devrait se dégrader dans le
futur notamment du fait du déficit de
croissant de la Caisse nationale de
retraite des agents des collectivités
locales la CNR à Cl
les branches familles et autonomies si
elles conservent un excédent
respectivement de 1,9 et 0,2 milliards
d'euros les voies d'ores et déjà se
réduire car la progression de leurs
dépenses est plus rapide que celle de
leur recette seule la branche accident
du travail maladie professionnelle
bénéficient d'excédents solides
les contes de la sécurité sociale sont
donc déficitaires mais certains sont
aussi de plus de plus en plus
insincèrent en effet l'exercice 2022 a
été marqué par le refus de la Cour des
comptes de certifier les comptes de la
branche maladie et de la knaf un quart
des montants versés au titre de la prime
d'activité est ainsi affectée d'erreurs
non corrigée 9 mois après leur paiement
la nécessité de mieux lutter contre les
abus et contre la fraude sociale que le
Sénat a maintes fois défendu s'en trouve
réaffirmé en toute état de cause nous ne
pouvons donner qui tue au gouvernement
de sa gestion dans les conditions un mot
pour terminer sur l'endettement social
en 2022 la dette sociale a atteint un
pic inédit de
160,1 milliard d'euros or la diminution
programmée des ressources de la Cadès la
remontée des taux d'intérêt vers les
hauteurs vertigineuses et la probabilité
grandissante que de nouveaux passifs
soient transférés à la CADES compte tenu
de la dégradation prévisible des comptes
sociaux font craindre un nouveau
repoussement un nouveau repoussement de
l'horizon d'extinction de la dette
sociale au-delà de 2033
le tableau que je vous peins est sombre
des recettes dont la dynamique ne
manquera pas de s'épuiser des dépenses
mal maîtrisées en constante augmentation
un sol qui demeure fermement négatif et
un endettement social inédit dans ces
conditions mes chers collègues la
commission des finances vous invite à
rejeter ce projet de loi je vous
remercie merci
[Musique]
la parole est carrément de penser monche
pour le groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur chers collègues
l'objectif de cette première loi et non
seulement d'approuver les contes de la
sécurité sociale mais de tirer les
enseignements de l'exécution de l'année
achevée afin d'examiner à l'automne le
prochain budget loin d'être une simple
compilation de données comptables le
texte de loi apparaît jusqu'à ses
annexes très politiques et nous en
ferons également une lecture politique
tout d'abord la dynamique des comptes
rester préoccupantes car si les
administrations de sécurité sociale ont
un sol comparable à celui d'avant la
crise sanitaire la sécurité sociale sans
intégrer les autres administrations et
très déficitaires notamment la branche
maladie toujours en attente du tournant
préventif mais aussi comme précisé dans
les annexes du fait de l'assèchement du
financement de la protection sociale par
des dispositifs alternatifs au salaire
non soumis à cotisation de moins en
moins compenser que vous n'avez de cesse
de renforcer ainsi les composantes des
rémunérations les plus dynamiques
contribuent aujourd'hui moins au
financement de la sécurité sociale en
2022 les exonérations ciblées non
compensées sont en hausse de 11%. le
coût total des mesures d'exonération
d'allègement et d'exemption d'assiette
augmente fortement avec un coût global
s'élevant après de 80 milliards sur le
champ des régimes obligatoires de base
de la sécurité sociale le coût net des
exemptions d'assiettes dépassent 10
milliards et marque une hausse de 6%.
alors même que selon les annexes il
reste pourtant difficiles d'évaluer la
perte de cotisation de sécurité sociale
qui résulte de l'ensemble des
dispositifs d'exemption d'assiettes vous
menez et accélérez une politique
d'incitation auprès des employeurs à
contourner des augmentations pérennes de
salaire vous produisez ainsi pièces par
pièce loi après loi hier celles du
pouvoir d'achat de masse du partage de
la valeur
le déficit de la Sécurité sociale
méthodiquement pour éclairer la
reconduction ou non de ces niches
sociales la loi organique de mars 2022 a
prévu une évaluation de leur efficacité
pour un tiers d'entre elles chaque année
afin que chaque mesure fasse l'objet
d'une évaluation tous les trois ans ce
n'est pas une évaluation des niches
sociales tous les trois ans monsieur le
ministre mais chaque année une
évaluation d'un tiers des niches il est
temps contenu des pertes de recettes
qu'elles occasionnent à la sécurité
sociale quand elles sont non compensées
ou de leur coup pour le budget de l'État
de produire cette annexe afin d'éclairer
le Parlement d'autres annexes s'avèrent
non conformes aux obligations
d'information tendue Parlement que des
citoyens notons comme la commission
l'absence de l'indicateur sur la
création de place en crèche en 2021 et
2022 alors que c'est achevé l'objectif
d'en créer 30000 net de 2018 à 2022 il
est vrai qu'on est loin du compte et ce
alors que le nouveau plan quinquennal on
promet désormais 100 000 comment dès
lors en juger
le dépassement de l'ONDAM était fatal et
s'avère programmée pour les exercices à
venir la cour des contes le notent la
progression moyenne annuelle sur la
période 2023 2026 serait de 2,9 % soit à
peine plus que l'inflation alors que
nous savons que l'évolution mécanique
due au vieillissement démographique à
l'innovation médicale et aux maladies
chroniques et de plusieurs points en
volume où est donc messieurs les
ministres la sincérité des prévisions
comme le sens des dépassements le seuil
d'alerte est privé de son intérêt et
n'entraîne pas de loi rectificatifs
réservé semble-t-il aux réforme de
structures un peu plus
quand aux excédents débranches familles
autonomie et ATMP elle traduisent aussi
l'insuffisance des politiques ou de leur
application
insuffisance de résultats du plan crèche
de la lutte contre la pauvreté qui
concerne un enfant sur 5 pour la branche
famille des accidents et maladies
professionnelles pour la branche ATMP
attendent de la loi grand âge pour la
branche autonomie il est ainsi des
excédents non vertus sans assister sur
le refus partielle de certification de
la Cour des comptes nous constatons que
loin de permettre un chaînage vertueux
de cette loi et du futur PLFSS ce projet
de loi suscite plus de questions que
d'information cette photo des comptes et
non seulement floue mais en partie
incomplète et un propre à nous permettre
d'espérer par l'analyse une inflexion
des politiques budgétaires à l'automne
c'est pourquoi le groupe écologiste
solid arité et territoire votera contre
je vous remercie merci la parole est
maintenant à tany Mohamed swahili pour
le groupe RDPI
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre dans le président de la
commission madame la rapporteur général
chers collègues le projet de loi que
nous examinons cet après-midi correspond
à la première loi d'acrobation de compte
de la sécurité sociale qui consacre la
mise en place d'un cycle budgétaire
complet de vote de contrôle et
d'évaluation des finances sociales en
effet la dernière révision du cadre des
lois organiques
des lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale adopter un max 2022 a créé une
nouvelle catégorie de loi sur le modèle
du triptyque de loi de finances
la loi d'approbation des comptes de la
Sécurité sociale déposer avant le 1er
juin de chaque année permet ainsi de
constater et d'analyser les moyens
financiers effectivement mis en oeuvre
l'année précédente et d'évaluer les
politiques de sécurité sociale elle
renforce le contrôle parlementaire de la
gestion des administrations de sécurité
sociale et de ses régimes obligatoires
de base ce texte permet donc de
constater et d'analyser l'exercice clos
de manière particulière cet examen étant
auparavant rapidement évacué lors de
l'examen de la première partie du PVF
esss dont les débats se concentrer
principalement sur les mesures des
années à venir ce projet d'approbation
de compte de la sécurité sociale et donc
avant tout un exercice formel puisqu'il
constate et approuve les comptes de
l'année précédente
comme le mentionné le ministre chargé de
compte public lors de son audition par
la commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat ce texte est une photographie des
comptes exécutés dont le vote ne peut
engager le contenu du texte qui
appartient au passé nous pouvons donc
faire la comparaison entre ce texte et
les comptes administratifs des communes
qui sont le plus souvent votés même par
l'opposition à contrario du budget
présenté par l'équipe municipale qui
contient un impact politique beaucoup
plus important après ces considérations
de forme entrons dans le fond du sujet
la situation financière des contes de la
sécurité sociale doit être replacé dans
le contexte des difficultés économiques
auxquelles nous faisons face avec la
sortie de la crise sanitaire et le
surcoût de l'énergie
nous sommes aujourd'hui en sortie de
crise mais le contexte inflationniste
continue de peser lourdement sur le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages ainsi
l'année 2022 a été marquée par une
amélioration globale de la situation des
finances de la sécurité sociale en
comparaison à l'année 2021 avec une
situation moins favorable que prévu par
rapport aux prévisions pour 2022 de la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 le déficit des régimes
de base et du fond de solidarité
vieillesse a diminué de 4,6 milliards
d'euros en 2022 par rapport à 2021 pour
atteindre 19,6 milliards d'euros
les raisons principales sont l'inflation
la bonne tenue de l'emploi la
surexécution des dépenses liées à la
crise sanitaire et la revalorisation des
prestations sociales
l'analyse de nos comptes sociaux nous
démontre que trois branches sur 5
autonomie famille et accident du travail
maladie professionnelle sont
excédentaires et que les deux autres
vieillissent ces maladies demeurent
déficitaires nous devons donc agir en
responsabilité et maintenir nos efforts
pour établir l'équilibre de ses branches
à cet égard nous pouvons nous féliciter
de voir la situation du marché de
l'emploi s'améliorer ce qui nous permet
de mieux financer notre modèle social
par l'augmentation des cotisations
en effet pour la 7ème année consécutive
le chômage diminue en France
s'établissant à 7,3% en moyenne annuelle
en 2022 337
000 emplois ont été créés en 2022
l'équivalent de 5 milliards de recettes
supplémentaires pour la sécurité sociale
ces chiffres encourageant mettent en
exergue l'importance du travail dans
l'amélioration des comptes de la
sécurité sociale
plus de travail mais également une
meilleure redistribution en effet la
Cour des comptes dans son rapport
d'application des lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale prévue au moment du
dépôt de la loi d'appréhension de compte
à estimer que le coût de la fraude de
prestation sociale serait compris entre
6 et 8 milliards d'euros le gouvernement
a par ailleurs récemment annoncé
plusieurs mesures pour lutter contre
l'Afrique sociale parmi ces mesures
certaines concernent la lutte contre le
travail non déclaré la fraude de
prestation de santé aux prestations
sociales la mise en place d'un véritable
conseil d'évaluation de la fraude sera
également une réelle avancée à laquelle
nous souscrivons ces annonces très
attendues de la part de nos concitoyens
permettront de rétablir plus de
confiance envers notre pacte social
pour toutes ces raisons et en
responsabilité notre groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants votera en
faveur de cette approbation de compte de
la sécurité sociale 2022
merci
la parole est maintenant a bien enjônier
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur général
mes chers collègues c'est donc une
première c'est la première fois que nous
est examinons une loi d'approbation des
contes de la sécurité sociale et c'est
un progrès dans la procédure
parlementaire de délibération des
comptes sociaux même si ce progrès reste
bien mince ainsi que nous l'avions
souligné lors de l'adoption de la loi
organique l'instituant bien mince car le
renforcement du rôle et du contrôle du
Parlement passerait par une procédure en
amont de l'adoption de la LSS qui ne se
limiterait pas à l'octroi de délai hanté
examen rallongé mais un parcours qui
débuterait par un débat politique avant
l'été sur le cadrage et les objectifs de
nos politiques sociales et de santé
parcours et débat sans lequel les
allocations de moyens et les arbitrages
qui en découlent échappent largement au
parlementaires mais aussi et c'est une
grande faiblesse de notre démocratie
sociale elle échappe aux acteurs
concernés et ces acteurs ne comprennent
pas d'ailleurs cette décoration entre
les plans qui sont multiples entre les
stratégies nationales qui sont tout
aussi multiples les annonces
gouvernementales et la réalité des
financements
l'adoption du budget social et santé de
la nation devrait être ce le temps de ce
lien et il ne l'est pas
bon nous n'en sommes donc pas à cette
procédure que nous appelons de nos vœux
et nous nous contenterons donc de clore
le cycle annuel des finances sociales
pour constater les montants financiers
effectivement mis en oeuvre l'année
précédente mais également évaluer les
politiques de sécurité sociale alors si
nous devions limiter notre rôle comme je
l'ai entendu de la part du ministre des
comptes publics à une forme de
ratification administrative et bien les
motifs de rejet seraient déjà pas tant
ainsi que la relevée très justement la
rapporteur les erreurs dans les comptes
difficiles à admettre lorsqu'ils avaient
déjà été relevés et qu'ils ne sont pas
corrigés mais aussi et surtout le refus
de la Cour des comptes de certifier cela
branche famille amènera
inéluctablement tous les législateurs
rigoureux à émettre un vote négatif
la Cour a par ailleurs relevé que les
hypothèses du gouvernement relatives au
compte sociaux sont très optimistes je
cite et l'évolution prévisionnelle des
dépenses de santé particulièrement
ambitieuse je cite aussi la sincérité
est donc à minima questionner
le gouvernement souhaite inscrire
lambdam dans une pardon dans une
progression quasiment égale à
l'inflation en raison de l'évolution des
caractéristiques de notre population
cela correspond en fait à une régression
des moyens à louer vous tracez ainsi le
même sillon celui d'une contrainte
financière forte alors que les besoins
de financement sont importants alors si
au moins cette approche financière
amenait nos comptes sociaux à
l'équilibre mais non vos projections
sont celles d'un maintien de déficit à
l'infini une fois encore une fois de
plus je veux redire qu'il s'agit d'un
choix politique que le maintien d'une
sécurité sociale en déficit envoie le
message d'un système social trop coûteux
d'une charge pour la nation et une
charge évidemment il faut la réduire
c'est la ligne politique de ceux qui
considère que les cotisations sociales
ne sont que des charges à diminuer qui
considèrent que la politique de soutien
aux ises doit être supporté par notre
système social et de fait c'est vous qui
opposez soutient aux entreprises et
systèmes de protection sociale en
refusant de procéder à une révision
complète de l'efficience des multiples
exonérations accordées ces dernières
années
il est pourtant possible d'équilibrer
les comptes entre 2014 et 2018 parce
qu'il existait des années avant 2017
quoi qu'on pense le gouvernement le
recul du pacis net a été constant appuyé
sur la réduction du déficit des régimes
de base et du FSV les résultats de la
CADES et du FFF pardon du fond de
réserve des retraites on conduit à
dégager un résultat consolidé positif
oui les multiples impacts positifs y
compris sur la cohésion du pays de notre
système de sécurité sociale peuvent se
conjuguer avec son équilibre financier
mais vous n'y arriverez pas vous n'y
arriverez pas car vous faites un refus
d'obstacle sur la question des recettes
que vous limitez aux effets bienvenus
bien sûr mais insuffisants du taux
d'emploi et de l'évolution spontanée des
salaires et vous n'y arriverez pas parce
que votre approche des dépenses est
comptable vous ressortez toujours les
mêmes illusions d'économie ah les arrêts
de travail ah les indemnités
journalières toujours la vieille lune de
la maîtrise des contes mais juste sur ce
point je regardais le rapport de la
Caisse nationale d'assurance maladie
et que dit son analyse
Césarée ces indemnités journalières sur
la dernière décennie ont progressé de
80%
c'est énorme mais voilà cette hausse en
disant elle expliquait par la hausse des
actifs par la hausse des salaires et en
particulier du SMIC par des épisodes
épidémiques particulièrement importants
et par un des parents retraite plus
tardif et est la situation ne risque pas
de s'arranger en résumé il n'y a pas de
dérive de ces inconscients de médecins
traitant vos propos les propos du
ministre des comptes publics sur les
arrêts du vendredi ou du lundi relève de
l'anecdote et ne sont pas à la hauteur
vos services ont lancé une chasse qui
est vaine
et que dire de la situation de l'hôpital
qui symbolise l'écart entre la
satisfaction du gouvernement et la
réalité
pour notre part nous appelons le
gouvernement à revoir fondamentalement
son approche du budget santé principal
source actuelle de déficit et là encore
je voudrais citer le rapport de la Cour
des comptes qui dit et je cite l'enjeu
principal c'est de mettre en œuvre au
plan local une stratégie territorialisée
qui associe l'hôpital public les
cliniques privées à but de lucratif ou
non la médecine libérale et les
collectivités territoriales monsieur le
ministre le pilotage actuel a démontré
ses limites il faut en changer or vous
persister votre gouvernement gère mal la
sécurité sociale quand on met en regard
l'ampleur des déficits et l'état du
système de santé mais mon groupe
souhaite que cette laque soit débattue
jusqu'à son terme elle ne souhaite pas
un approuvera pas la motion procédurale
elle demande l'examen complet du texte
pour exprimer notre opposition sur le
fond à la ligne politique qui l'incarne
je vous remercie
merci maintenant c'est l'horos Cohen
pour le groupe que républicain
communiste écologiste
ah oui
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le projet
de loi d'approbation des contes de la
sécurité sociale de 2022 a été inaugurée
en bonne et due forme par un rejet de
l'Assemblée nationale par 134 voix
contre 115 et le dépôt d'une motion de
la majorité sénatoriale nous laisse
présager un avenir tout aussi funeste au
Sénat nous nous en réjouissons par
avance d'autant que nous avions dénoncé
lors de l'adoption de la loi messnier
qui prévoyait la création de la laque la
volonté de rapprocher la présentation
des contes de la sécurité sociale de
celle du projet de loi de finance au
mépris de l'autonomie budgétaire de la
Sécu et ce dont le seul objectif de
renforcer l'étatisation et la
fiscalisation de notre système de
sécurité sociale cette loi d'approbation
des contes de la sécurité sociale
présentée comme une innovation et un
progrès pour le contrôle parlementaire
n’est en fait qu'une compilation de
certaines annexes du plfs en réalité ce
texte ne vise qu'une seule imposer de
nouvelles restrictions des dépenses
sociales en sciences publiques à
l'Assemblée nationale monsieur le
ministre des comptes publics qui n'est
plus là a rendu un hommage appuyé au
120000 agents des caisses de sécurité
sociale et il vient de réitérer ses
compliments au Sénat mais le 22 juin
dernier le cadenas enchaîné révélé que
le gouvernement avait l'intention de
supprimer 1720 postes à la sécurité
sociale d'ici à 2027 drôles de façon de
remercier les agentes et les agents de
la sécurité sociale ces suppressions
d'emploi s'ajoutent à celles des
précédentes conventions d'objectifs et
de gestion qui ont supprimé plus de 800
CDI entre 2018 et 2022 dans les cafs il
ne faut pas s'étonner si la Cour des
comptes a refusé de certifier les
comptes de la branche famille en raison
d'une augmentation importante des
paiements
erronés puisque les moyens humains ne
sont pas suffisants pour faire face aux
demandes et aux réformes décidées par le
gouvernement en 2022 l'ONDA mettait de
2, 2% alors que les besoins étaient
doubles puisque la progression
tendancielle des dépenses de soins est
estimée à 4%. entre temps l'impact de
l'inflation sur les dépenses de
fonctionnement a été estimée à 1,1
milliard d'euros supplémentaires et la
Fédération hospitalière de France a
réclamé 2 milliards d'euros pour
financer l'augmentation du point
d'indice l'austérité imposée à la
branche maladie en 2022 a conduit à la
fermeture la nuit faut-il le rappeler
ici de 80 services d'urgence 131
établissements ont été concernés par des
fermetures de lit 30% des patients
atteints de maladies chroniques ont été
contraints de reporter leurs soins et
des milliers de soignantes et soignantes
ont démissionné de l'hôpital cette
photographie déconne de la sécu en 2022
illustre les conséquences de
l'obstination du gouvernement a séché
les contes de la sécurité sociale le
rapport de mal de mars 2023 de ligase et
de l'IGF a permis de recenser les
mesures de réduction et d'exonération de
cotisation ou de contribution de
sécurité sociale il a recensé 150
dispositifs pour un montant total de
67,5 milliards d'euros pour les
entreprises en 2022 contre 59,6
milliards en 2021 et 78,8 milliards
d'euros prévus en 2023 vous allez
m'objecter que ces mesures ciblies ont
été compensées par l'État certes
monsieur le ministre mais à hauteur de
91%, laissant une ardoise 2,5 milliards
d'euros à la sécurité sociale et je ne
parlerai pas de ces 191% de compensation
qui pourrait servir à développer les
services publics ce texte illustre
également les conséquences du refus du
gouvernement de prendre en charge les
coûts de la pandémie de covid-19 et le
transfert de l'addition sur le dos de la
sécurité sociale concernant la lutte
contre la fraude sociale le rapport de
la Cour des comptes offre un éclairage
intéressant puisque la majorité de la
fraude correspond à celle des employeurs
au travail dissimulé pour un montant
estimé de 8 milliards d'euros ensuite
celle des professionnels vous sentez
pour 4 milliards d'euros et enfin la
fraude des assurés sociaux qui arrive en
dernier avec 2,5 milliards d'euros sur
l'ensemble des prestations familiales
nous sommes donc loin des discours
véhiculés par certains pour stigmatiser
les plus précaires et les étrangers une
fois de plus ce texte illustre les choix
du gouvernement qui s'obstinent à
refuser de dégager de nouvelles recettes
en mettant à contribution les
entreprises et les revenus financiers
comme notre groupe ne cesse de le
proposer vous préférez monsieur le
ministre utiliser l'argent des assurés
sociaux et des citoyens via l'impôt la
CSG la TVA pour financer les mesures
d'exonération des cotisations patronales
pour toutes ces raisons et par cohérence
avec notre vote contre la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2022 le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologiste votre acompte cette
loi d'approbation des contes de la
sécurité sociale pour 2022 je vous
remercie
merci la parole est maintenant à Michel
Canevet pour le groupe Union centriste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je souhaite
vous rappeler le contexte de l'adoption
de la réforme de la l'offre de la
sécurité sociale avant d'évoquer notre
Constitution ces années après l'adoption
de la dernière loi organique relative
aux lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale deux propositions de l'organique
avaient été déposées en mars 2021 au
Sénat par notre collègue Jean-Marie
vanderenberg alors rapporteur général
dont je salue le travail et en mai 2021
à l'Assemblée nationale par Monsieur
Thomas Meunier député rapporteur général
et visant toutes deux à rénover le cadre
organique de des lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale
l'adoption de cette réforme s'était
faite sans difficulté politique avec le
soutien du gouvernement
et ne laissait présager aucune
difficulté de mise en oeuvre à l'époque
Olivier dussobe ministre des comptes
publics s'exprimait ainsi devant
l'Assemblée nationale les deux
propositions de loi organique et les
deux propositions de loi qui les
accompagnent constituent des avancées
décisives pour le pilotage de finances
publiques et pour les pouvoirs du
Parlement avant de continuer ainsi la
proposition symétrique de Thomas Meunier
consistant à prévoir la création d'un
projet d'approbation des comptes de la
Sécurité sociale déposés au printemps et
tout à fait opportuné le Gouvernement
soutiendra cette disposition
ensuite
selon notre Constitution à l'article 24
le Parlement vaut de la loi et nous
l'effectuons après des débats riches de
nos différences et de notre diversité
à l'article 21 de notre Constitution il
est dit que le premier ministre dirige
l'action du gouvernement les
responsables de la défense de la nation
et assure l'exécution des lois donc la
loi organique adoptée promulguée
s'impose dans son intégralité dès son
entrée en vigueur et le gouvernement
doit en assurer l'exécution par le biais
de ses services
sauf quand l'espèce est contre toute
attente la loi de l'approbation des
contes de la sécurité sociale que nous
examinons aujourd'hui et qui nous est
soumise n'a pas été intégralement
exécuté par exemple les rapports
d'évaluation des politiques de sécurité
sociale n'indiquent pas les résultats
atteints lors des trois dernières années
comme la loi organique le prévoit outre
ce relatif à l'exécution financière de
même et cela a été dit l'annexe relative
au niche social ne comporte pas
d'évaluation des mesures concernées
pour quelle raison soit le gouvernement
n'arrive pas à obtenir de ses services
un projet respectant les exigences de la
loi organique alors que les services à
la tâche sont reconnus pour la grande
qualité d'expertise et leur réactivité
soit l'exécutif considère que
l'information des parlementaires n'est
pas une priorité et il serait
regrettable de ne pas vouloir informer
correctement les Français de l'usage qui
a été fait de leur cotisation sociale
lesquels sont encore au nom de au sens
de le groupe de l'Union centriste trop
élevé dans notre pays et devront à terme
être réduites effectivement pour
améliorer la compétitivité de nos
entreprises n'en déplaisent à
quelques-uns dans notre assemblée
alors sans aborder avec précision le
fond des dispositions cela fut
particulièrement bien détaillé par notre
excellente rapporteur général Elisabeth
Doisneau dont je salue la qualité de
l'analyse je relèverai simplement deux
points qui au-delà de la forme justifie
également le vote de la question
préalable sur le déficit de la Sécurité
sociale alors que nous venons demander
aux Français un effort important
concernant l'assurance vieilles il est
temps de nous attaquer au déficit de
l'assurance maladie notre collègue
Jean-Marie vanloenberg visait déjà en
2017 des actes inutiles et redondants se
basant sur un rapport de l'OCDE il
expliquait je cite 28% des actes
prescrits sont jugés par les médecins
eux-mêmes n'est-ce pas monsieur le
ministre docteur
non pleinement justifié rapporté aux
dépenses d'assurance maladie ce sont de
l'ordre de 50 milliards d'euros
potentiellement concernés
dans cette droite digne et en dépit des
actes de correction mise en place depuis
la Cour des comptes émet une demande
appuyée concernant l'amélioration de la
maîtrise médicalisée en effet
elle nous dit que malgré 30 années de
mise en oeuvre la rend la France reste
éloigné des pays les moins dispendieux
soit une différence de l'ordre de 11 à
19 milliards d'euros par an grevant
ainsi l'assurance maladie soit environ
150 milliards de dépenses cumulées sur
10 ans
nous regrettons également sur
l'exécution de la loi que le cahier des
charges prévu en application de
l'article 44 de la loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2022 n'était
toujours pas publié ce matin alors qu'il
aurait dû être lettre avant le 30 juin
de cette année
voilà ceci étant dit monsieur le
ministre je voudrais également
vous dire que la grève des praticiens
hospitaliers qui aujourd'hui et demain
matin affecte l'ensemble du territoire
national montre bien les attentes
extrêmement fortes qui demeure malgré
l'action mise en oeuvre tout comme sur
chacun de nos départements les membres
de l'Union centriste voudraient vous
rendre attentif à la difficulté
budgétaire auxquelles sont affrontées
les établissements et services sociaux
et médico-sociaux sur beaucoup de
médico-sociaux et hospitaliers bien
entendu on voit bien sur les territoires
partout que dans les EHPAD il y a des
déficits importants qui
s'annonce qui ont déjà été constatés en
2022 dans les établissements
hospitaliers il en est souvent de même
malgré quelques crédits non
reconductibles qui peuvent être alloués
par les agences régionales de santé ceci
montre bien que malgré des efforts qui
sont fait malgré une situation difficile
il reste encore pour ce qui concerne la
mise en oeuvre dans notre pays des
politiques
médico-sociales et médical des attentes
extrêmement fortes sur le terrain auquel
il convient que le Gouvernement
s'attache et que nous puissions ensemble
essayer de trouver les voies et moyens
permettant d'apporter à l'ensemble de
ces services les moyens de fonctionner
dans de bonnes conditions voilà quelques
messages monsieur le ministre chers
collègues le groupe de l'Union centriste
souhaitait aujourd'hui vous diffusez
nous voterons lac dans notre grande
majorité la question préalable proposée
par la commission des affaires sociales
merci de votre attention
pour le groupe RDS
monsieur le madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres madame la
Présidente de commission Madame et
Monsieur les rapporteurs chers collègues
nous examinons aujourd'hui le premier
projet de loi d'approbation des contes
de la sécurité sociale que nous savons
souhaité décorréler du PLFSS avant
d'expédier à l'automne l'approbation des
contes de l'année précédente avant
auparavant expédié à l'automne cette
fois-ci l'approbation des contes de
l'année précédente fait aujourd'hui
l'objet d'un projet de loi à part
présenter chaque année au mois de juin
et accompagner d'un rapport de la Cour
des comptes ces conditions d'examen
devraient et doivent permettre
d'améliorer le pouvoir de contrôle du
Parlement en matière de finance de la
sécurité sociale dans son rapport la
Cour des comptes estime qu'à travers les
tableaux d'équilibre et le tableau
patrimonial le Plax pour 2022 fournit
une représentation cohérente des
recettes des dépenses et du sol de la
sécurité sociale toutefois d'autres
éléments suscitent des préoccupations le
maint dans le projet de loi de chiffres
erronés pour 2021 je détaillerai pas
cela a été dit l'absence de mise à jour
d'indicateurs nécessaires au suivi de
l'efficacité voire de l'efficience des
politiques publiques comme par exemple
nombre de places en crèche ou
l'évaluation des niches sociales et
enfin les comptes 2022 de la CNAF et de
la branche famille que la Cour des
comptes refusés de certifié en raison
d'une augmentation problématique du taux
de paiement
erroné et qui ne sont d'ailleurs pas
mentionnés en annexe de cette loi quand
visagez-vous messieurs les ministres
pour faire baisser le nombre d'erreurs
du paiement de la CAF
enfin et vous l'aurez compris les marges
de progression attendues sont
importantes et en cela je rejoins la
rapporteur Elisabeth Doisneau que je
salue au passage pour son travail et la
pédagogie dont elle fait toujours preuve
mais rappelons qu'il s'agit d'un premier
exercice et je tiens à ce moment de la
discussion rappeler la position
constante du groupe RDSE de s'opposer
aux motion préalable et de toujours
privilégier le débat concernant la
situation financière 2022 si le solde
global des administrations de sécurité
sociale retrouve son niveau d'avant
crise avec un excédent de 9 milliards
les régimes obligatoires de base
demeurent eux très déficitaires c'est
essentiellement la branche maladie qui
plombe les comptes avec un déficit de 21
milliards du fait des restes de la crise
sanitaire et des mesures prises face à
l'inflation que nous avons tous pensé
nécessaire le déficit est toutefois
moins élevé que prévu et réduit de plus
de 4 milliards par rapport à 2021 grâce
à des dépenses allégées sur le front du
covid
mais l'objectif n'assumer l'ONDAM
dépasse encore de 10 milliards la
prévision faite fin 2021 avec les crises
qui se succèdent il devient
manifestement de plus en plus difficile
d'anticiper le niveau des dépenses je me
joins donc à ceux qui réclament leur
établissement du seuil d'alerte en cas
de risque dépassement de la dame et au
moins un PLFSS rectificatif qui
permettrait à la représentation
nationale dans des bases la branche
vieillesse c'est quand elle déficitaire
de près de 4 milliards pour y faire face
une réforme des retraites vient d'être
adoptée il conseille d'orientation des
retraites le corps projette déjà un
déficit persistant et une impossibilité
de retrouver l'équilibre en 2030 alors
que début janvier le président de cette
même instance écartait d'urgence de la
réforme messieurs les ministres
considérez-vous que le modèle n'est pas
viable sur le long terme est une réforme
globale est déjà envisagée
s'agissant des branches familles et
autonomie toutes deux excédentaires des
questions se posent aussi sur les années
à venir en effet le manque de place
notamment en crèche et les fortes
tensions de recrutement appellent à
envisager des augmentations de dépenses
dans la petite enfance et le
médico-social une situation donc moins
favorable doit déjà doit également être
anticipé ce plaque est aussi l'occasion
de préparer et c'est peut-être ça le
plus intéressant le PLFSS pour 2024 mais
surtout de se poser la question de la
meilleure utilisation des finances
publiques non pas uniquement pour
aboutir un équilibre financier certes
nécessaires mais surtout pour répondre
aux besoins de santé de nos concitoyens
face aux grandes transitions
démographiques technologiques
épidémiologiques que nous traversons il
serait illusoire d'espérer un système
constant une baisse de nos dépenses de
santé et je crois que piloter
l'ondamment de manière économique n'est
effectivement pas suffisant nous avons
des leviers puissants vertueux et
efficace à actionner que sont la
prévention l'éducation à la santé et
l'innovation
notre groupe souhaite porter votre
attention sur les attentes fortes des
professionnels de santé sur le terrain
si des mesures utiles monsieur le
ministre comme la vaccination et les
visites médicales obligatoires ont été
prises je crois qu'il faut aller encore
plus vite et encore plus fort se fixer
un cap en matière de prévention il
inscrire dans une stratégie de moyens et
de long terme une loi de programmation
pluriannuelle d'ailleurs proposée par le
Sénat lors des PLFSS précédents peut en
être le véhicule malgré ces points de
vigilance la majorité du RDS du rdsa ne
s'opposera pas à l'approbation des
contes et je terminerai simplement par
une citation de gens Monnet l'un des
pères fondateurs de l'Europe qui dit que
les hommes n'acceptent les changements
que dans la nécessité et ils ne voient
la nécessité que dans la crise je crois
que le moment du changement est
largement venu
la parole est maintenant encore une
inverse pour le groupe les républicains
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur général mes chers
collègues
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
pour donc sur l'exécution du budget de
la Sécurité sociale pour 2022 et si les
contes de la sécurité sociale de l'année
écoulée était jusqu'à leur arrêté à la
première partie du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale leur
approbation fait dorénavant l'objet d'un
texte distincte tout le monde l'a dit
c'est une première elle est vidange je
me réjouis à l'idée qu'il renforce
l'information du Parlement et des
citoyens sur la situation des comptes
sociaux cette lumière faite est un
maillon supplémentaire à notre vie
démocratique et à la transparence que
nous devons à nos concitoyens
dommades les finances publiques ne
peuvent que s'apparenter à un long
sentier austère ardues escarpée pourtant
rien ne mérite davantage que l'on s'y
aventure en voyant loin sinon claire
avec résolution et acharnement mais non
que l'on s'y abandonne parce qu'elle
donne corps entre autres à la sécurité
sociale grâce à l'effort qu'on sentit de
nos concitoyens et des entreprises elle
consolide notre pacte républicain gage
de solidarité
oui le ministre des comptes publics a
dit tout à l'heure l'économie crée la
richesse richesse qui financent la
solidarité toutefois il nous faut
éclaircir et aller au delà de ce que les
chiffres et les constats illustres
puisqu'ils sont avant tout le reflet de
choix politiques en matière de sécurité
sociale alors je pourrais l'exprimer
différemment le déficit de la Sécurité
sociale est-il une fatalité
concernant l'année 2022 je ne peux que
regretter l'annonce certification de la
branche famille par la Cour des comptes
en raison notamment de l'augmentation de
la proportion des paiements erronés
sur la forme encore la Cour a également
déploré les dates de production
moyennant une réduction de 4 mois des
délais d'analyse par les juridictions
financières par rapport à la situation
qui prévalait jusqu'en 2021 15 jours
pour examiner les comptes et les
rapports des commissaires aux comptes
mes chers collègues vous en doutez cela
est bien trop peu
par ailleurs en tant que rapporteur de
la branche maladie du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale je
constate non pas sans grand
désappointement que la quasi-totalité de
l'augmentation du déficit depuis la
crise sanitaire provient de la branche
maladie en effet les dépenses de santé
après avoir augmenté lors de la crise
sanitaire n'ont pas diminué depuis pour
partir en faisant de l'inflation mais
également raison du Ségur de la santé
malgré tout ces 21 milliards d'euros de
déficit de la branche maladie ont permis
d'assurer la prise en charge des
dépenses de santé engagées alors que le
déficit toute branche y compris le front
de solidarité vieillesse s'élève à 19,6
milliards d'euros
permettez-moi de m'attarder sur
l'objectif national des dépenses
d'assurance maladie
si de 2011 à 2019 l'ONDAM avait
systématiquement été respecté il ne l'a
plus été depuis en raison de la crise
sanitaire et des mesures prises pour
compenser l'inflation ainsi l'exécution
de la dame 2022 montre une nouvelle fois
un dépassement par rapport à la dernière
prévision actualisée en loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale 2023
pour l'année 2022 ce dépassement et
cette année encore substantiel par
rapport à la prévision initiale
puisqu'il se chiffre à plus de 10
milliards
d'euros milliards d'euros et qui n'est
plus le seul fait de la crise sanitaire
ainsi mes chers collègues l'ONDAM
désormais de près de 250 milliards
d'euros ne semble pas pilotable même si
le directeur de la CNAM nous a affirmé
en commission qui le restait encore pire
mais surtout pas à même de rendre compte
au législateur des actes effectifs des
dépenses des choix politiques du
gouvernement encore moins de les
arbitrer cela était vrai en loi de
financement initial comme désormais vrai
en loi d'approbation la question du
pilote du pilotage de long terme est
clairement posée
un minimum le Parlement devrait pouvoir
l'examiner sous objectif par
sous-objectif cette demande ne paraît
légitime comparée aux missions du budget
général et vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
le ministre le budget de la Sécurité
sociale en montant est bien supérieur au
budget général donc d'émissions de le
dont le niveau de dépenses est souvent
inférieur au montant de chacun des sous
objectifs mission qui elles sont votées
une par une
pour 2023 le comité d'alerte dans son
avis du 7 juin a appelé à une grande
vigilance la Cour des comptes par
ailleurs semble apporter le même
discours d'alerte et souligne que la
progression de l'âme est actuellement
prévue est inférieur à la dynamique
d'inflation ce qui conduit conduira à
exercer une forte contrainte évidemment
inacceptable sur les acteurs de santé en
particulier sur l'hôpital public mais
également sur les acteurs du
médico-social cela a été dit par ma
collègue à l'instant le comité d'alerte
doit jouer pleinement son rôle
je vous le dis je vous le dis cela n'est
plus tenable nous avons besoin d'un
homme sincères et utile avec un
découpage fin des dépenses qui distingue
notamment celle liés à des
remboursements répandant assurances
sociales des dépenses pilotables que
sont les dotations
par ailleurs nous devons nous devons pas
perdre de vue notre objectif la
recherche constante d'un équilibre dans
la maîtrise de l'évolution des dépenses
et améliorer chemin faisant l'état de
santé des Français à ce titre je citerai
le constat aussi bien explicite
qu'alarmant de la Cour des comptes selon
lequel il existe je cite des risques
élevés portant sur la souteabilité de la
dette publique française à moyen terme
et si Manon qui n'est plus possible de
repousser le nécessaire redressement des
finances publiques et donc des comptes
sociaux il est fini le temps où la dette
apportait de l'argent à ce jour la
cadèse peut encore absorber une dette de
8,8 milliards d'euros quand le déficit
de la Sécurité sociale prévu pour 2023
est annoncé à 8,2 milliards d'euros
l'examen des comptes de la Sécurité
sociale est indispensable au travail de
contrôle qui nous échoue en tant que
parlementaire a fortiori quand ils sont
le reflet de choix politiques en matière
de solidarité et de santé tout cela
s'inscrit dans un contexte où la
médecine d'ovril est toujours aussi
fragile où les hôpitaux n'ont pas
retrouvé leur niveau d'activité de 2019
c'est à dire d'avant la pandémie
présentant des déficits conséquents et
des établissements accueillants des
personnes âgées ou des personnes
handicapées présentant eux aussi des
déficits les uns et les autres étant en
prime confrontés à des difficultés de
recrutement enfin considérant l'avis de
la commission des finances de notre
haute assemblée et même si nous aussi
nous aimons et nous sommes très
attachées au débat faute d'un exact
comme la souligner le rapporteur général
et compte tenu de la non conformité à la
loi organique au nom du groupe les
républicains je vous invite mes chers
collègues à adopter la motion pendant à
opposer la question préalable présentée
par Madame la rapporteur général
Elisabeth Doisneau dont je salue le
travail je vous remercie
merci
la parole est maintenant à Vanina
paoliaga pour le groupe Les Indépendants
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le projet de loi que nous avons examiné
aujourd'hui et qu'il ne sera d'ailleurs
peut-être pas si ta question préalable
est adoptée est une première cela a été
dit une création issue de la révision du
14 mars 2022 nous saluons à ce titre
cette possibilité nouvelle donnée au
Parlement et permise par cette révision
d'étudier les comptes de l'année su
distinctement du temps accordé à
l'examen du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale
ce projet de loi laisse apparaître
quelques points positifs déjà
identifiés trois des cinq branches de la
sécurité sociale sont excédentaires la
branche famille pour 1,9 milliards la
branche autonomie pour 200 millions et
la branche accident du travail et
maladie professionnelle pour 1,7
milliards
par ailleurs les 337 000 emplois créés
en 2022
représente 3 milliards d'euros de
cotisations en plus pour la sécurité
sociale qui s'ajoutent à celles dégagée
par le million d'emplois créés depuis
2017 sur ce point nous espérons que le
projet de loi France travaille dont nous
aurons l'occasion de débattre très
prochainement permettra de raccourcir le
chemin tracé jusqu'ici par le
gouvernement vers le plein emploi mais
ces chiffres ne suffisent pas à effacer
le plus critique d'entre eux
19,6 milliards d'euros c'est le montant
de déficit de la Sécurité sociale pour
2022 et nous en convenons tous c'est un
montant colossal
il est dû pour 3,8 milliards au déficit
de la branche retraite nous ne referons
pas le débat sur les retraites ici mais
le déficit quasi constant de cette
branche et bien la preuve que la réforme
des retraites était une nécessité
indiscutable mais le déficit de la
Sécurité sociale et surtout due cela a
été souligné pour 21 milliards à celui
de la branche maladie les dépenses si
elle a crise sanitaire dont l'impact a
encore été très significatif en 2022
même si il a été moins qu'en 2021
ne pèse néanmoins que pour près de
pardon oui non pardon excusez-moi ne
pèse néanmoins que pour près de 12
milliards d'euros dans les comptes de
l'Assurance Maladie un travail important
est donc à conduire sur le reste
notamment sur l'explosion des arrêts
maladie les indemnités journalières ne
représentant pas moins de 15 milliards
d'euros par an avec une tendance
malheureusement constante à la hausse
travail tout aussi important que celui a
mené contre la fraude sociale et les
erreurs cela a été dit le refus de la
Cour des comptes de certifier les
comptes de la branche famille même s'il
n'est pas inédit n'est tout de même pas
anodin et doit sérieusement être pris en
compte surtout quand ce refus résultat
un nombre d'erreurs en augmentation de
plusieurs milliards d'euros dans les
versements du RSA de la prime d'activité
et des aides au logement au-delà des
erreurs s'ajoute la fraude à l'assurance
maladie celle aux aides sociales et
celles relatives au travail dissimulé il
n'est inacceptable qu'au total près de
15 milliards d'euros destinés à la
solidarité nationale et à la pérennité
de notre système de protection sociale
soit ainsi détournée
là encore nous doutons pas que le plan
de lutte porté par le ministre des
comptes publics contre la fraude sociale
et les mesures pour lutter contre les
erreurs permettront des améliorations
concrètes et nous verrons surtout à ce
que l'augmentation des moyens permettant
les contrôles soient bien effectifs
enfin il a été souligné en commission
que l'on dame n'était plus respectée
depuis 2020 pour la première fois depuis
2011 certes mais c'est aussi la première
fois depuis 2011 que notre pays a fait
face à une pandémie mondiale d'une telle
ampleur suivi d'une telle inflation
c'est aussi une première pour les
hôpitaux
que de bénéficier de tels après avoir
été longtemps sous-financé et les
soignants sont payés toutefois la crise
des hôpitaux est encore loin d'être
terminée et beaucoup restent à faire
pour eux tout comme en faveur de la
compagnement de l'autonomie nous aurons
l'occasion de discuter des orientations
budgétaires que nous souhaitons pour la
pérennité de la sécurité sociale à
l'automne comme à son habitude et parce
que nous souhaitons débattre le groupe
des indépendants votre a contre la
question préalable je vous remercie
merci l'addition générale est maintenant
terminée et nous allons donc passer la
discussion dans la motion préalable
pendant de la mousse son temps à opposés
la question préalable et la parole est à
Madame Elisabeth Doisneau pour la motion
merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
je veux redire en quelques mots ce que
j'ai dit au préalable en introduction et
en même temps je me suis exprimé sur sur
l'idée que l'on se fait de cette
première finalement loi d'approbation
des comptes de la Sécurité sociale qu'il
ne faut pas confondre avec une loi
d'appréciation de la politique de
sécurité sociale parce que je crois que
on est sur un exercice nouveau et que
dans les propos des uns des autres j'ai
senti qu'il y avait aussi voilà besoin
d'exprimer son avis sur la politique si
oui ou non on était d'accord ou pas là
on est bien sur une loi d'approbation et
je veux rappeler qu'une loi
d'approbation c'est une loi d'évaluation
le moindre héros je dirais d'engager
parce que c'est aussi bien en termes de
recettes qu'en termes de dépenses il
doit être évalué
utile ou non c'est pour ça que nous
avions demandé dans la loi organique
qu'il y ait effectivement
une évaluation de l'efficacité
d'efficience des niches sociales parce
que là ces niches sociales ou allègement
et bien il faut les regarder à la loupe
est-ce que nous avons bien fait à
l'époque de les proposer de les voter
est-ce qu'ils ont encore aujourd'hui une
raison d'être en tout cas nous avons
plusieurs raisons et nous les avons nous
les avons donné tout à l'heure de
proposer cette motion qui tend à opposer
la question préalable alors je pour tous
ceux qui souhaitaient débattre c'est
sans doute une frustration mais la
réalité c'est que pour débattre il faut
aussi tous les éléments et nous pensons
que nous les avons pas tous donc je
pense que vous aurez à travers ces
quelques propos une réaffirmation de ce
que j'ai pu dire au préalable merci
merci comme il n'y a pas d'orateur
inscrit pour faire le contre je vais
solliciter la vie du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs et sénata alors vous proposez
effectivement de rejeter le Plax sur un
certain nombre d'arguments alors comme
c'est et vous l'avez dit un exercice
nouveau je me permets juste quatre
précisions sur des arguments que vous
avez mis en avant s'agissant du refus
par la Cour des comptes de certifié les
comptes de la branche famille
effectivement pas une première si je
peux m'exprimer ainsi vous le savez nous
avons d'ores et déjà pris toutes les
dispositions pour répondre aux
observations de la Cour investissement
massif dans les systèmes d'information
fiabilisation du calcul des prestations
lutte contre la fraude
en ce qui concerne la cohérence des
données présentées dans les tableaux
d'équilibre la Cour des comptes que vous
citez d'ailleurs dans votre propos à
préciser précisément valider ces
tableaux tels qui sont présentés dans le
projet de loi d'approbation des comptes
de la sécurité sociale
pour les annexes au projet de loi je
vais d'abord préciser qu'elles offres
l'information la plus exhaustive est la
plus actualisée au Parlement à jour vous
auriez souhaité avoir l'indicalité des
240 indicateurs du placs avec les
données de la fin 2022 nous transmettons
au Parlement les données les plus
récentes mais lorsqu'elles sont
disponibles nous travaillons d'ores et
déjà à rendre ces données disponibles le
plus tôt possible
enfin concernant les niches sociales je
veux soulignais le travail d'ampleur qui
a été initié dès l'automne 2022 qui a
débouché sur la remise du rapport de
Ligue 1 cette IGF publié au moment de la
présentation du placs qui présente le
cas de méthodologique pour l'évaluation
justement de ces niches sociales au
cours des prochaines années
j'en profite pour remercier les
administrations au premier chef la
Direction de la Sécurité sociale qui a
permis d'élaborer ce texte à l'issue
plusieurs mois de travail je tiens en
profiter pour les saluer et bien
évidemment vous l'aurez compris que je
suis défavorable
madame poncer Monge pour une explication
de voiture a-t-il d'autres explication
de vote
oui merci madame la Présidente alors
selon l'article 47.2 de la Constitution
les comptes des administrations
publiques sont réguliers et sincères il
donne une image fidèle du résultat de
leur gestion de leur patrimoine et de
leur situation financière or ce projet
ne répond pas à ses exigences vous
refusez de prendre en compte les
corrections votées par le Parlement vous
vous exonérer de la production
d'indicateurs prévus par la loi
organique de mars 2022 vous ne
fournissez pas les informations sur
l'évaluation des mesures d'exonération
et d'exemption de cotisations et
contribution de la sécurité sociale
monsieur le ministre Gabriel Attal nous
a répondu que
les évaluations des niches sociales
suivront le rythme prévu c'est à dire
une évaluation tous les trois ans or la
loi organique prévoit une évaluation de
l'efficacité des mesures de réduction ou
d'exonération pour au moins un tiers
d'entre elles chaque année cette année
cette évaluation manque et cela est
d'autant plus préjudiciable que beaucoup
d'études en pressante l'inification
inefficience ce n'est qu'une des
non-conformités des annexes à la loi
organique
contrario d'un autre projet de loi qui
lui n'aurait pas dû utiliser le ce
véhicule législatif le dépassement de
l'ONDAM n'a pas fait l'objet d'une loi
de rectification rectificative et d'un
débat parlementaire donc nous partageons
une partie des attendus de cette motion
mais mesureront aussi l'intérêt d'avoir
enfin un débat sur la une loi
d'application isolée du prochain budget
c'est pourquoi le groupe écologiste
s'adiendra je vous remercie
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues cela a
été précisé ce projet de loi est un
outil de contrôle mis à la disposition
des parlementaires pour constater et
analyser les moyens financiers
effectivement mis en oeuvre l'année
précédente afin d'évaluer les politiques
de sécurité sociale il permet donc
d'améliorer notre information sur
l'ensemble des administrations publiques
de la sécurité sociale ce projet
d'approbation des comptes et avant tout
un exercice formel puisqu'il constate et
approuvent les comptes de l'année
précédente cela fait intégralement
partie des missions et la raison d'être
de notre institution en effet au terme
de l'article 24 de la Constitution le
Sénat vote la loi contre l'action du
gouvernement et évalue les politiques
publiques cet outil nous permet donc
d'exercer notre pouvoir de contrôle sur
un bilan comptable du passé ce n'est pas
un exercice politique l'adoption de la
motion ne changera en aucun cas les
comptes de l'année 2022
nous devons au contraire nous concentrer
sur le redressement des deux branches
déficitaires et sur les moyens à
développer concrètement pour améliorer
la trajectoire de nos comptes publics ce
débat nous l'aurons à l'occasion de
l'examen du belfss 2024 pas à l'occasion
du constat et de l'analyse des chiffres
du passé notre groupe pour l'ensemble de
ces raisons votera donc contre la motion
pendant à opposer la question préalable
bien comme il n'y a pas d'autres
explications de vote et que le scrutin
public est de droit sur la question
préalable nous allons donc maintenant
voter sur cette question préalable le
scrutin est ouvert
315 pour 200
contre 115
donc la motion est adoptée
alors puisque la motion est adoptée le
texte est considéré comme rejeté et nous
allons
lever la séance et la prochaine aura
lieu demain matin mardi 4 juillet à 9h30
pour les questions orales
la séance élevée